et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
stanislas bonjour vous êtes le délégué
général de la république en marche on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est de ouest france
bonjour stéphane bonjour bonjour et on
commet stanislas guérini avec ce qui se
passe à dijon depuis plusieurs jours
plusieurs nuits ces affrontements entre
communautés tchétchène et maghrébine
alors laurent lyonnaise a annoncé hier
un renfort de 150 gendarmes et est ce
qu'il aurait fallu que l'état
intervienne plutôt de manière plus ferme
est ce qu a eu du laxisme l etat est
intervenu puisque depuis vendredi
dernier en réalité les forces de l'ordre
sont sur place elles ont fait un travail
admirable d'ailleurs et ma première
pensée c'est pour les dijonnaises et
pour les dijonnais parce que c'est vrai
que ce qu'ils ont vécu
c'est intolérable c'était un
affrontement de bandes de cette nature
là mais l'état les policiers on était
présent et il faut d'ailleurs saluer
leur travail quand j'entends que
certains veulent les désarmer ce n'a
absolument aucun sens on voit bien que
nous avons besoin d'une présence
policière
c'était important que le rendu neige
puissent se rendre sur place annoncent
un renforcement encore des forces en
présence pour mettre fin à ce qui était
une situation totalement intolérable de
faire réagir à ce tweet de christian
jacob le patron à des républicains qui
dit depuis devait depuis quelques jours
notre pays est en proie à une explosion
de violence le silence du premier
ministre résonne comme un aveu
d'impuissance coupable qu'est ce que
vous lui répondre mais on voit bien qu'à
chaque fois des responsables politiques
veulent mettre de l'huile sur le feu
rajoutez systématiquement de la
confusion à des situations qui sont
difficiles on sait que dans les
quartiers
il y à des situations difficiles tout le
monde craignait que la période qui
suivrait le confinement puisse être une
période de tension c'est le cas la seule
réponse c'est une réponse républicaine
c'est à dire à la fois d'avoir l'ordre
l'ordre républicain
c'est la réponse de laurent d'une hes de
christophe castaner et puis agir pour
ces quartiers-là agir concrètement nous
le faisons depuis le début de ce mandat
en dédoublant des classes en mettant des
emplois francs il faut continuer sur
cette voie là mais je ne fais pas partie
de ceux qui systématiquement veulent
mettre de l'huile sur le feu
crois qu'il faut beaucoup évoqué cherche
à mettre de l'huile sur le feu on voit
bien qu'à chaque fois en dix ans le
président de la république ne parle pas
suffisamment vite le premier ministre
devrait s'exprimer comme ci comme ça je
crois que la démocratie continue sa
route il ya les questions au
gouvernement le premier ministre de
l'intérieur ont systématiquement
l'occasion de répondre aux questions
c'est ainsi que ça doit continuer le
ministre de l'intérieur il a le ton
juste oui
sa tâche est extrêmement difficile et
moi quelle hauteur
je le pense je pense depuis deux ans il
agit extrêmement concrètement au delà
des discours au delà des mots pour que
l'on puisse donner plus de moyens aux
forces de l'ordre depuis le début de ce
quinquennat c'est plus d'un milliard de
crédits supplémentaires que nous avons
débloqué et ça c'est l'action de
christophe castaner quand nous créons
les postes de police et gendarmes
savaient avant christophe castaner ya
certains policiers qui attendait le
paiement de leurs heures supplémentaires
depuis 2005
pour certains il a pris des décisions
justement de reconnaissance envers le
travail de nos forces de l'ordre ça au
delà des discours
ce sont des actes il faut continuer
comme ça je crois que il ya ceux qui
s'agitent mais qui n'avait pas fait dans
lé quinquennat précédent ou au contraire
qu'ils avaient fait dans l'autre sens
qui avait détruit côté les services de
renseignement territoriaux qu'avait
détricoter le nombre de policiers et de
gendarmes
et puis il ya ceux qui agissent
christophe castaner fait partie de ceux
là et là mon soutien plein et entier je
vois bien qu'il ait attaqué ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est par exemple hier est
ce que ce n'était pas à lui d'aller à
dijon c'est laurent nunez qui semble
pardon mais je vois tout ce qu'ils
veulent faire de la politique
politicienne par rapport à cela il y à
un mini jeu intérieur et un secrétaire
d'état qui fonctionne bien qui sont sur
le terrain
le rendu neige se déplace à dijon on
devrait pouvoir se réjouir qu'il est
justement à beauvau ce couple-là de
quatre jours d'affrontements jours et ni
pourquoi ça à luminy ce sens rien
pectoral politicienne à chaque fois
qu'il ya quand même des tensions entre
le ministre lui même et le
la police enfin les hommes de rang ça se
passe pas toujours bien surtout les
forces de l'ordre et manifester une
forme de colère par rapport aux attaques
dont ils font l'objet
eux qui depuis deux ans font face encore
une fois de façon admirable a beaucoup
de violence a beaucoup de mouvement et
on sait à quel point les samedis qui ont
suivi pendant la crise des gilets jaunes
ont été difficiles pour nos forces de
l'ordre elles sont fatiguées
ça c'est vrai elles ont besoin de
reconnaissance de la nation
nous devons leur apporter cela et donc
il y à ce mouvement là je crois que
christophe castaner tient cette ligne de
crête elle est difficile parce qu'on
voit bien que beaucoup veulent nous
mettre dans un piège terrible
hier c'était la journée où marine le pen
d'un côté disait n'importe quoi que
paris était tout était en train d'être
cassé à paris paris est à feu et à sang
je crois que ça a été extrêmement fo
christophe jean lannes l on dit qu'il
faut désarmer la série voilà nous nous
tenons ce blog un dernier mur sur
christophe caceres ce ne sont pas que
des attaques politiques ce sont les
policiers eux mêmes qui ont dit qu'il se
sentait lâché qu'il était désavoué que
pour eux christophe castaner n'était pas
le premier film de france c'est pour ça
que je reconnaissais je faisais le
distinguo entre ce qui me semble être
des attaques politiciennes et ceux qui
expriment notre police aujourd'hui qu'il
faut savoir entendre il faut répondre à
cela je crois que à la fois les mots de
christophe castaner cette semaine à
l'assemblée nationale les mots du
président de la république dans son
intervention
on était juste il n'y a qu'une seule
réponse c'est celle de l'ordre
républicain et c'est celle là que nous
allons continuer à apporter
vous parliez de marine le pen elle était
en déplacement hier à dijon et elle a
notamment proposé d'instaurer le
principe du casseur payeur y compris
pour les mineurs en engageant la
responsabilité civile des parents est ce
que pour vous c'est une bonne mesure
mais là encore marine le pen ne
manifestent jamais une hauteur de vue
celle qui veut être une femme d'état
elle vient faire des coups politiques
pour agiter raconter n'importe quoi sur
les situations elle ne fait ça matin
midi et soir et en ce moment elle ne
fait que cela donc je crois qu'il faut
prendre de la distance
les interventions se font la police est
là pour contenir
c'est ce qu'elle a fait
y compris à dijon et donc je ne veux pas
me livrent à une sorte de surenchère
politicienne ce qu'ils veulent sur ce
cas des situations beaucoup de gens se
posent qui doit réparer les dégâts reste
que le principe du casseur payeurs c'est
une mais quand il ya des manifestations
il ya des organisateurs qui sont
responsables et donc c'est comme ça que
nous devons continuer afin là en
l'occurrence à dijon oui mais il faut
interpeller
voyez les les manifestants quand ça
effet il y a en suite des procédures
judiciaires qui doivent évidemment
suivre leur cours
je crois pas que soient les grands
principes comme ça qu'ils puissent
répondre à sexuellement mais pas qu'à
dijon on voit bien aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'en france on ne sait
plus organiser une manifestation 104
débordements et qui ne sont pas le fait
des organisateurs de lait reçus
j'avais raison ça devient quasi
systématique qu'est-ce qu'on fait par
rapport à ce genre de choses bien on
interpelle c'est nous avons pris des
mesures l'année dernière pour justement
pouvoir interpeller au mieux interdire
de manifestations à certains de
personnes sortir des manifestations ceux
qui ont le visage couvert par exemple et
donc tout cela nous devons continuer à
le faire
mais au delà des grandes déclarations
nous devons agir dans les actes on voit
bien que ces manifestations sont volés
hier comment les soignants revendique
légitimement manifestent dans le calme
il y a des forces d'extrême gauche des
casseurs qui viennent piller créer du
désordre
et bien cela il faut les condamner être
absolument intraitable et ne pas tout
confondre effectivement sur la
manifestation elle-même que vous venez
d'évoquer les soignants en fait comment
est-ce que vous interprétez ce ce type
d'action alors qu'il ya eu tant de
promesses faites pendant la période de
crise qu'est-ce-qui pourquoi il le comte
clignet part je crois que c'est de
l'impatience qui est manifestée c'est
juste que ça les on sait bien que la
situation à l'hôpital est très difficile
je crois que cette période nous a montré
à quel point nous avions besoin de
réinvestir dans notre système de santé
nous avions commencé à le faire très
activement mais le compte n'est pas
encore il faut aller plus vite et tu
viens d'où il ya aussi un doute sur les
promesses qui ont été faites le ségur de
la santé a été lancée il y aura des
réponses très précises qui seront j'en
suis convaincu à la hauteur de la
situation de
hôpital mais les soignants manifeste
c'est un patient cela ils veulent dire
qu'il ne souhaite pas après la période
que nous avons vécu être oublié faut
évidemment les entendre mais surtout
être dans l'action c'est ce que fait
olivier ferrand en travaillant sur le
ségur en concertation avec justement
tous les acteurs de la santé pour
apporter des réponses concrètes
ça sera le cas ce sera où le mois de
juillet moi je sais le mais qu'est ce
qu'ils gagnent cette fois sera la bonne
c'est vrai on entendait l'espagne hier
dans les manifestations d'hier il ya eu
beaucoup de discours il ya eu beaucoup
de mots et très peu d'actes qu'est ce
qui dit qu'est ce qui leur donne
aujourd'hui les acteurs on l'a d'abord
et il ya eu des actes depuis un an avec
le plan ma santé 2022
la direction était la bonne sur la
réorganisation de l'hôpital sur la
reprise
on a repris quand même 10 milliards de
dettes de l'hôpital pour pouvoir
justement réinvestir tout ça ça n'est
pas rien il y a eu des revalorisations
mais il faut aller plus vite et plus
fort et donc nous allons continuer à le
faire
je crois que nous avons une certaine
crédibilité pour le faire parce que nous
avons commencé à agir concrètement au
delà des mots et puis il faudra
continuer à faire cela
le mois de juillet ce n'est pas très
loin maintenant il y aura des réponses
concrètes
je pense que olivier ferrand les
apportera près que les soignants verront
concrètement est ce que les larbins sur
la neige par exemple ça ne changerait en
pouvoir d'achat des hausses eu déjà des
revalorisations elles doivent être plus
importante c'est l'engagement de cette
majorité de ce gouvernement il sera tenu
par les allocutions des manuels alors
moi je voulais oui je voulais évoquer
l'emploi la situation des jeunes parce
qu'on voit bien que c'est un des points
c'est un des points clés vous avez
xavier bertand qui équipe qui plaide
pour zéro charges salariales et
patronales sur l'embauché d'un jeune en
cdi
est-ce que vous soutenez ce genre de
proposition j'avais en réalité fait la
même proposition
je voudrais vous l'appliquez pardon et
vous l'appliquez alors là vous savez
qu'il ya des bonnes propositions aucun
problème pour ce épique et les uns les
autres je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
difficultés là dessus ce qu'est
évidemment partagée c'est une inquiétude
extrêmement forte pour notre jeunesse la
situation de crise qui touche notre
jeunesse aujourd'hui on était elle est
terrible elle touche toutes les
catégories de jeunes ce qui était déjà
en difficulté les plus précaires ceux
qui ont pacs
r un emploi saisonnier qui étaient des
décrocheurs et puis elle touche aussi
les jeunes qui terminent leurs études
qui se destinait peut-être un emploi de
cadre et qui vont avoir beaucoup de
difficultés parce qu'ils n'ont même en a
la trouille du travail qu'on est
d'accord pour dire que c'est les moins
de 25 ans qui vont payer le plus lourd
tribut dans la partie dans le volet
c'est de la remise de la crise et le
risque et c'est là qu'on va chuter sur
ce gouvernement veut tout faire pour que
cette génération là qui a fait beaucoup
de sacrifices pendant la crise ne soit
pas la génération sacrifiée du coc vide
19 nous avons fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour sauver nos aînés et bien il ne faut
pas que cette génération la paye toutes
les dettes la dette environnementale
sociale économique de l'emploi
donc nous devons agir mais le verrez des
leviers des leviers c'est d'abord celui
de l'emploi de l'accompagnement oui je
veux tout faire pour que à la rentrée
chaque jeune de france cette génération
là est une solution une solution ça veut
dire quoi
une activité un accompagnement et un
revenu soit parce que il sera dans
l'emploi soit parce qu'il sera
accompagné par une mission locale par
pôle emploi
il faut avoir tous les dispositifs
mobilisés et donc oui j'ai formulé des
propositions pour effectivement mettre
le paquet sur l'emploi des jeunes des
primes à l'embauché pour les primo
accédants marché du travail
zéro charges pour tout premier cdi
signée quelle que soit la rémunération
le salaire puisque vous savez que nous
avons déjà beaucoup diminuer les charges
sur les emplois à plus faible
rémunération est ce que salon ont cassé
par le par l'extension du rsa aux moins
de 25 ans par exemple je crois qu'il
faut marcher sur ses deux jambes la
jambe de l'envol wars est de faire je
viens de le dire
et puis la jambe sociale effectivement
pour accompagner les plus précaires et
j'avais effectivement fait cette
proposition pour que au delà de savoir
si le rsa c'est le bon outil ou pas il
peut y avoir des débats légitimes sur
cette question là mais qu'on puisse
mobiliser en réalité de façon plus
efficace plus large plus automatiques
aussi tous les dispositifs existants il
y en a de nombreux jeux peuvent être
destinés aux jeunes je pense à la
garantie jeunes par exemple et bien
qu'on puisse à la fois rendre ces
dispositifs plus puissant et plus
efficace parce que plus automatique
nous avons ouvert un chantier qui le
revenu universel d'activité bien c'est
le bon chantier pour justement permettre
d'automatiser et de flécher plus
rapidement les aides
sourisseau ne rencontre pas un écho très
favorable au gouvernement gabriela
talent qui était sur notre antenne lundi
dit que ce n'est pas forcément la bonne
solution
je l'entend bien elle se débat il faudra
l'avoir je crois que ce que nous
partageons avec gabriella talent qui est
en train de préparer un plan d'envergure
pour la jeune génération c'est ça qui
est important c'est que nous puissions
mobiliser tous les dispositifs existants
pour qu' il puisse être à disposition
est automatiquement à disposition des
jeunes qui n'auront besoin
est-ce que ça doit porter le nom de rsa
de garantie jeunes ce qui m'importe
c'est qu'il est sur le compte en banque
des jeunes car les besoins la bonne aide
au bon moment aucun jeune ne doit rester
sur le bord de la route un mot sur cette
phrase d'emmanuel mâcon qui a fait
beaucoup parler en ce fameux travailler
davantage nous devrons travailler et
produire davantage est-ce que clairement
il va falloir rouvrir le débat sur le
temps de travail je crois pas que ce
soit ce débat là qu'il s'agisse de
rouvrir particulièrement quand nous
avons défiscalisé les heures
supplémentaires et qu'en réalité c'est
un débat qui est largement derrière nous
ce que ça veut dire à mon sens c'est
qu'il faut faire repartir l'activité
dans notre pays l'industrie aujourd'hui
ses 60 % d'activité après la période de
confinement et de crise que nous avons
vécue bien c'est ça l'enjeu c'est de
faire en sorte que l'on puisse apporter
des emplois à tout le monde d'abord est
donc cette bataille là nous étions en
train de la gagner
nous étions en train de gagner la
bataille contre le chômage de masse il
faut évidemment la reprendre c'est la
priorité des priorités pour la suite de
ce cas comme il ya juste un autre débat
qui revient sur la table c'est celui-là
la tva sociale est ce que vous vous êtes
favorable à un retour de la tva sociale
non je crois pas que ce soit la bonne
mesure dans le sens où nous avons besoin
de recréer de l'activité et les mesures
qui touchent la tva sont des mesures qui
peuvent être intéressantes quand il ya
un niveau d'activité qui est déjà là et
donc moi je crois que nous devons plutôt
agir en apportant des aides directes à
ceux qui en ont besoin
en incitant ceux qui ont de l'épargné à
pouvoir investir dans les entreprises
consommer est plutôt aider directement
les entreprises de ce pays là pour tenir
des secteurs d'activité debout je crois
que ce mix de réponse là est plus
pertinent que les modulations adopté
vers un autre sujet la convention
citoyenne pour le climat tient son
dernier week end
de travaux ce week-end cette fin de
semaine qu'est ce que est ce que vous
avez une idée des conclusions qui vont
sortir de ces travaux et qu'est-ce que
comment est ce que le gouvernement ou
présidents vont s'emparer de ce qui va
sortir du chapeau d'abord moi je me
réjouis que ce travail là et plus se
poursuivre j'avais plaidé c'était les
propositions de la république en marche
pour qu'on mette en place ce type de
convention particulièrement pour le
sujet prioritaire du 21ème siècle qui
est la transition écologique et donc
c'est une bonne chose que cette
convention ait pu mener ses travaux au
bout je suis favorable à ce que nous
puissions reprendre le maximum de
propositions qui font consensus à
travers ses 150 citoyens qui ont pu
travailler que éventuellement nous
puissions les se mettre un référendum je
ne suis pas du tout opposé à cette idée
là pour que justement ça soit un choix
de société on voit bien que sur des
questions qui sont des questions
complexes c'est aussi pour cela que
c'est une bonne chose d'avoir ce type de
convention parce que cela place tout le
monde face à la complexité des sujets
mais quand nous parvenons à créer du
consensus et c'est ce que permettent de
faire ce type de convention et bien
qu'ensuite on puisse entraîner la
société c'est cela nous avons besoin et
donc je suis très favorable à ce qu'on
reprenne de façon pleine et entière les
propositions de cette convention c'est
toi le président nous a dit dimanche qui
continue à consulter qui revient il
reprendra la parole au mois de juillet
ce sera pour nous annoncer ce qui fait
avec les résultats de la convention
citoyenne ou et/ou pour nous dire qu'il
va changer de gouvernement
alors peut-être en partie pour la
convention citoyenne je crois je crois
que ce qui est très important c'est de
comprendre que nous vivons là un moment
d'urgence
nous sommes encore dans un moment
d'urgence sanitaire le virus circule
encore mais maintenant surtout
économique et social et puis s'ouvrira à
la rentrée un temps pour reconstruire
notre pays avec un nouveau gouvernement
nous avons besoin à ce moment là d'un
cap de priorité c'est très légitime et
normal que le président de la république
puisse le fixer ça doit d'abord être le
projet et puis ensuite la question de
l'organisation éventuellement qui
inverse dans total pour porter ce projet
là ça c'est le président de la
république qui le dira début juillet
alors les municipales vous aviez un
objectif de dix mille élus
encarté la république en marche est ce
que vous y êtes à l'issue du premier
tour ou pas loin puisque le deuxième
tour vous y mènera ou est-ce que vous
êtes très loin du compte finalement je
pense que au lendemain du deuxième tour
nous aurons dans toute la france une
nouvelle génération d'élus d'élus locaux
issus des rangs de la république en
marche et nous serons nous auraient dit
oui de lancer municipaux c'est aller
chercher une analyse les surtout dans
l'est parce que les listes les listes
qui ont été présentés aux seules
couleurs de la république en marche on
peut pas dire qu'elle est vraiment
performer dans ce premier tous avaient
arrêté à dans les grandes villes des
listes qui sont étiquetés avec des
appartenances partisanes et puis dans
beaucoup de communes de plus petite
taille des listes citoyenne sur lequel
il y avait de très nombreux marcheurs
donc si divers droite 10 générations la
guerre contrairement à ce qu'on entend
de temps en temps elle est dans toutes
tailles de ville
la république en marche on a souvent
voulu dire que c'était le party des
métropoles je crois que c'est pas vrai
du tout nous avons des adhérents qui
participeront à la vie communale à la
vie démocratique de ce pays dans toutes
tailles de communes et pour moi c'est
extrêmement important
nous aurons plusieurs centaines de
maires au lendemain cette élection
municipale ça compte aussi beaucoup pour
moi mais très peu très peu dans les
grandes villes est ce que ça pour vous
c'est un échec
nous avons participé à l'élection de mr
dans des grandes villes déjà élu au 1er
tour vous savez dans les mers que nous
avions officiellement investi ou soutenu
il ya quasiment 80 mère qui ont été élus
dès le premier tour
je m'en réjouis et deux dans des vols
moyenne nous ce que vous avez raté la
marche des grandes villes en fait dans
des villes moyennes mais symboliquement
quelle sera la grande ville dirigée par
un maire la belgique on marche à l'issue
de ce que jamais envisager cette
élection bourg en voulant dire voilà où
on veut planter le drapeau et d'ailleurs
je pense que ça serait pas un bon cadeau
d'une certaine façon à faire à nos élus
qui mène des campagnes locales que de
nationaliser la campagne en disant voici
dans quelle ville je veux planter le
drapeau la république en marche
j'ai jamais envisagé l'élection
municipale comme ça parce que c'est une
élection locale m'interroger sur mes
objectifs partisans mes objectifs il
était très clair c'était d'implanter
notre jeune mouvement nous existons
depuis trois ans à l'échelle municipale
je pense que nous y part
un draw lendemain du deuxième tour mais
je n'envisage pas cette élection comme
une élection partisane où il faut
planter des drapeaux
en revanche je me réjouis que demain
dans des grandes villes comme dans des
petites villes nous puissions participer
à beaucoup de conseils municipaux nous
puissions avoir beaucoup d'adjoints
beaucoup de maires aussi je les dis
plusieurs centaines je le pense au
lendemain du deuxième tour qui
permettront à notre mouvement d'être
mieux enraciné et surtout surtout est à
agir pour nos concitoyens je crois que
c'est ça la politique cela reste et cela
sauf que pour la lecture des résultats
on est d'accord qu'il vous fallait
quelques grandes villes et vous auriez
pu ou dû gagner paris par exemple vous
avez d'abord sénat à la fin du bal qu'on
paie les musiciens
et donc nous nous sommes en sa part
pouvant regagner paris mais je ne joue
jamais une élection pour la perdre
je crois que à paris on voit bien que
nous avons besoin de faire entendre
notre voix moi je peux pas me résoudre à
un affrontement entre anne hidalgo et
rachida dati qui ne portent deux visions
extrêmement antagonistes des méthodes de
gouvernance pour la maire de paris qui
rend finalement paris renfermée sur elle
même et je crois que cela nous avons
besoin de sortir
agnès buzyn elle porte cette voie là
elle aura l'occasion de l'exprimer il ya
deux débats d'ici le deuxième tour dont
15 ce soir mais agnès buzyn et hillion
nous continuons de façon très dynamique
notre campagne et je peux vous dire pour
me déplacer sur le terrain que l'accueil
est plutôt bon agnès buzyn et demie sur
une adhésion des parisiens à l'action du
gouvernement quand on voit les scores
des maires de la république en marche ou
des mères proche de la république en
marche est ce que vous ne dites pas
c'est quand même pas la bonne stratégie
non vous savez moi je me déplace
beaucoup je vais à la rencontre
notamment des commerçants dans ma
circonscription et j'entends beaucoup de
retours positifs sur l'action que cette
majorité que ce gouvernement a pu mener
pendant la crise que nous avons vécue
savez c'est rare d'entendre des
commerçants qui vous disent moi j'ai
fait une demande l'aide du fonds
exceptionnel de solidarité
trois jours plus tard j'avais l'argent
sur mon compte bien ça les gens
l'entendent les gens reconnaissent que
le gouvernement a été largement à la
hauteur pendant cette période là et donc
d'avoir des mères qui seront demain
justement des traits d'union pour bien
travailler avec cette majorité
présidentielle qui seront cohérent pour
l'attractivité économique des villes
bien ça sera une chance pour nos
concitoyens et ce message là il a
entendu qu'ils seront des grands
électeurs pour les sénatoriales en
septembre
au vu des résultats des municipales sur
combien de sénateurs vous misez pour
votre groupe
nous n'avons pas défini d'objectifs
chiffrés je crois que ce qui est très
important c'est que au sénat nous
puissions rassembler des sénateurs et
dessinatrice qui souhaitent travailler
de façon constructive avec cette
majorité cette majorité présidentielle
avec ce gouvernement
et c'est comme ça que nous allons
aborder les élections sénatoriales
c'est à dire que vous irez piocher des
dessinateurs de droite de gauche c'est
pas les utiliser à des sénateurs
étiqueté la république en marche qui
seront élus sur une étiquette la
république en marge à nous voulons
véritablement rassembler autour de la
majorité présidentielle le faire au cdas
une chambre qui fonctionne comme ça avec
des accords souvent de projet et je
pense que il faut suivre ce mode de
fonctionnement là donc c'est comme ça
que nous envisagerons élections
sénatoriales
une dernière question vient de parler du
sénat l'ambiance ou parlement c'est
comment avec les dix groupes aujourd'hui
et le fait que le le le groupe
majoritaire de la république en marche
s'est progressivement fracturée
qu'est ce qu'il en reste aujourd'hui il
leur reste une majorité qui votent les
textes vous le voyez plus largement
encore qu'au début du quinquennat dont
qui a envie d'agir pour l'intérêt
général du groupe il est tellement
solide et il va encore continuer à se
fragmenter
alors je pense pas qu'il va continuer à
se fragmenter ça mais cette question-là
de l'organisation des groupes
parlementaires elle est à mon sens
secondaires par rapport aux projets que
nous mettons sur la table à notre
capacité à créer de l'adhésion est ce
que je vois c'est que au parlement nous
votons très largement les textes il ya
une majorité qui ne manquent pas
gouvernement à mon sens c'est dans la
situation du pays que nous connaissons
le seul sujet important et merci
beaucoup merci stanislas guérini d'avoir
été avec nous